the final push to rescue the last of the
13 soccer players and their coach
trapped in a Thai cave is almost over at
least three more boys have been pulled
out so far this morning as we've
reported divers guided eight of the boys
to safety in the first two days of the
rescue effort
mark Strassmann went inside a similar
cave system in Florida to show us some
of the conditions the soccer team
endured for more than two weeks mark
filed this report from Marianna Florida
good morning I'm standing about fifty
feet underground in the only developed
cave for touring in the entire state of
Florida wild caves are much more
challenging in fact this space is about
as soft and family friendly as caving
gets but even here you do get a sense of
how someone could get into trouble in a
hurry this is the deepest point of the
cavern here here we're about 60 feet
below the surface park ranger billy
bailey took us into this half mile long
limestone cave and if you had scuba gear
could you go even further
sure temperature in here is what 65
degrees no matter what team is you
outside it's always about 65 degrees
here in the cave with all its twists and
turns parts of this 38 million year old
cave are just above the water table
during a heavy rain the water inside has
risen as much as six feet you wouldn't
be able to go into this part of the
Kaveri when it was flooded when that
happens the Park Rangers here get plenty
of warnings not so in Thailand another
difference this cave has been developed
the walkways are level railings and
lights are everywhere in a wild cave
you'd be spelunking or cave exploring is
crawling so you would need to knee pads
elbow pads helmet several sources of
light
Bailey showed us what it's like during a
caves natural state total darkness Wow
you know she cannot see your hand in
front of your face it's disorienting
really fast it also makes it impossible
to see all the stalactites and
stalagmites those limestone rock
formations jutting up from the ceiling
and floor in the dark
all this stuff can hurt sure if you hit
your head incidentally hers and when you
look at what's happening in Thailand
what goes
he's being scared not knowing what
tomorrow would bring it's just a feeling
of helplessness Billy told us that no
one has ever been trapped in here and
visitors are never more than five
minutes from an exit but remember in
Thailand that soccer team was trapped
more than two miles from daylight John
thank you